[Musik]
es geht aufwärts willkommen beim ein
video
wir haben fertig haben und ich hab noch
ein bisschen besuch von fünf gestörten
menschen deswegen wundert euch nicht
über irgendwelche hinter geräusche aber
ich muss jetzt auf jeden fall das video
jetzt aufnehmen weil sonst macht keinen
sinn weil ich mein lieber morgen jetzt
schon wieder weihnachten vorbei oder
einen schon morgen weil wir jetzt schon
den ersten meiner zeit deswegen weiß
sofort einkaufen und ich habe hier
einmal ein schoko nikolaus gekauft dann
ein schoko nikolaus und zum dritten noch
einen schoko nikolaus und cola
ich habe auch eine vanille kohle aber
die muss jetzt noch holen es ist
überhaupt nicht gut aus ok dann hattest
du ja okay und zwar okay moment ich weiß
noch kurz einen bretter und messer
okay leute sorry jetzt muss ich
eigentlich direkt nochmal sagen weil der
dummkopf eben mein kopf nicht
draufsatteln
also ich hab grad ein brett geholt ja
das hier ist ein bett und zwar machen
das richtig heftiges ich hatte dir schon
länger aber ich muss es halt jetzt
machen wollen uns weihnachten vorbei und
zwar machen wir heute schoko nikoläuse
aus cola
ich bin schon wieder nicht drauf oder
sauce in die krise einmal normal dann
haben wir einen spaten sondern haben wir
ein von der marke lindt kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich
ich bin ich nicht drauf ich glaube die
leute also es geht dann halt schon die
kühlbox also kühltruhe und dann sind das
wirklich die cola ist geworden
die nico leute sind okay wir machen
jetzt erstmal die nikoläuse auf eine
scheiße der iss kaputt gegangen so leute
hier ist der letzte der andere ist ein
der kaputt gegangen was ich jetzt vor
der kopf wird abgestellt und dann kommen
die cholera die kreiskasse wenn er jetzt
auch kaputt geht dann mache ich so
fertig mehr private warten das ist sogar
gut
okay wir haben jetzt cola und ich
bekomme und ich will jetzt die cola hier
rein und nein die sollte eigentlich
nicht auf surfen lümmel alter dein ernst
nimmt weiter offen kate hall kurzen zeit
als ich sagen ich mache was etwas von
meiner perspektive aus weil das macht
mehr sinn als von eur weil du einfach
nicht filmen können so films wie so ein
dreijähriger du hast doch noch gar nicht
gesehen
wir haben jetzt hier ein schoko nikolaus
der ist voll mit cola und wie ihr seht
die kohler läuft nicht raus jetzt
passiert folgendes wir machen einfach
wieder zu hören wir machen einfach
wieder zurück und dann kommt er in die
kühlbox okay okay man sieht an sich
eigentlich gar nicht das thema kaputt
war
er ist kaputt lange wollt ihr ihn haben
okay der kommt jetzt in die kühlbox und
dann müssen wir erstmal warten und
morgen habt ihr auch vernünftiges
bildmaterial es ist halt nicht so
einfach älter mit gewissen personen
hinter der kamera
okay dass gleich der kommen jetzt in die
kühltruhe erst renten und hier erst mal
guckt es wirklich drin ist ja leute
ursprünglich war mein plan wirklich alle
drei mit cola zu führen ich wollte auch
diese geile vanille kohle rein tun wenn
man mit vier flügeln das versucht dann
ist es schwer ja ja ich würde sagen wir
warten einfach bis morgen früh und dann
schneide ich diesen einen schoko
nikolaus auch und wirkt einfach mal was
draus geworden ist und dann habe ich
praktisch an einzelne irgendwo antworten
auf jeden fall habe ich dann leighton
das probiere ich dann mal zusammen mit
meinem bruder oder so und zurück für
dieses dumme video aber dies seien wir
ehrlich so an sich die idee ist nicht
schlecht
bei 10.000 live hallo sich diesen schoko
nikolaus dieses raum früh ich wünsche
euch eine angenehme nacht ich hoffe ich
kann mir auch gut schlafen
so wäre es viel nach elf ich hab ein
paar schon geschlafen und jetzt muss
eigentlich ich hoffe mal die cola ist
fest geworden und wir können bisher zum
aufschneiden
also der ist jetzt eigentlich freuen mit
und ich kann jetzt auch schneiden
ich glaube dass noch flüssig drin
[Musik]
eigentlich dachte ich jetzt ich habe
nämlich so lodge alles weißt du weißt
was nämlich eigentlich gedacht habe dass
die schokolade und weg machen kann und
das ist dann hier sind nikolaus steht
aber ich glaube das ging nicht wegen der
kohlensäure sommer schmeckt nach
schokolade mit cola
[Musik]
ich will doch nichts über einen micro
merkel und lula und wohl auch probiert
man gute leute eigentlich hab ich mir
jetzt komplett anders vorgestellt
und ich war von meiner idee ursprünglich
sehr überzeugt jetzt ist du was
rausgekommen
du weißt was ich zu sagen soll es
schmeckt sehr gut für nächstes jahr zu
weihnachten gibt es uns erstmal schoko
nikoläuse mit cola ich muss halt auch
ein bisschen ein konzept feilen
wenn wir noch die einwandern tricks
überlegen aber dann wird das klappen ich
hoffe es hat euch bisher unterhalten wir
sehen uns morgen wieder
ich wünsche euch frohe weihnachten alles
liebe für diese family ein englisches
danke ich hoffe ihr habt eine schöne
zeit und die habe ich auch von mir auf
instagram alex wir uns natürlich am
meisten und jetzt trinkt in der